in this video we are gonna talk about
something called a CDN and a content
delivery network now the concept of a
CDN isn't that hard director head around
what CDN does is make a faster and
smoother user experience by delivering
content to the user faster it doesn't
have to go through all the channels of
the internet it creates a faster and
more direct route from the site to the
user what I first was learning about
CDNs I got really confused because I
thought well doesn't everybody benefit
from that who's paying for the service
is that the user they'll pay for a CDN
to make their internet faster or is that
the website that pays a CDN to deliver
their content and it's the latter a CDN
is hired by a website or in some cases
developed by a website it is a CDN then
thats TV ad pays an internet service
provider to help determine the fastest
routes now what you need to know about
CDN is in the big picture is they're
hired by sites or created by sites to
make the user experience faster an
example of a CDN that you should know
about as a developer is how Google hosts
languages like jQuery if you link to
jQuery from Google's library instead of
uploading it yourself to your site
that's going to be way faster for your
user additionally if another site has
used that same CDN for jQuery it might
be stored in that users browser so it
doesn't even have to load again all as a
user you need to know that CD ends are
everywhere you probably use CD ends all
the time without really even needing to
be aware as a developer it's important
for things like the languages that are
hosted on Google libraries you can use
those in your sites and create a much
faster user experience with less work on
your end than before adds a big company
you might need to see the end to do
something specifically for you you might
want your site to be on the fast track
to your users and you might need to see
the end to do that all I want you to
take away from this video is that CD
ends are content delivery networks they
are all over the place
they make a faster user experience